FENTANYL TO ADDICTS, BUT STOVES
ARE A THREAT TO YOUR LIFE?
PEOPLE USE GAS STOVES FOR A
LIVING, SOME RUN RESTAURANTS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU'RE A RESTAURANT OWNER, THIS
IS NOT A LUXURY, THIS IS CORE TO
YOUR BUSINESS.
WOULD YOU OBEY A BAN ON GAS
STOVES?
WHY ARE THEY SUPERIOR TO
ELECTRIC?
FOR 35 YEARS, WE'VE BEEN
ATTACKED BY EVERYBODY.
ORGANIZED CRIME AND CORRUPT WALL
STREET AND FOR LAST THREE YEARS,
WE'VE HAD GOVERNMENT OVERREACH.
WE'VE SEEN IT DURING COVID, THEY
DID THINGS AND NEVER FOLLOWED
THE SCIENCE AND WHAT IS GOING
ON, I HEARD A RUMOR LAST YEAR
AND WHAT I'M HEARING TODAY FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TO GOO
GOVE
HOCHUL, THEY WANT TO MAKE US USE
ELECTRIC STOVES.
WE LOSE 40% PRODUCTIVITY BY
USING ELECTRIC, BY USING
ELECTRIC, IF THEY INQUIRE WITH
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, THREE
PIECES OF ADVICE, GET STRONGER
FILTRATION SYSTEM, GET A HOOD
SYSTEM THAT, WOS AND TRAIN YOUR
STAFF HOW TO MAINTAIN IT.
FOR 35 YEARS, WEE CONTINUOUSLY
HAVE OBSTACLES RUNNING OUR
INDUSTRY.
TUCKER, THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
SMALL BUSINESS, SINCE LAST TIME
I WAS ON, YOU INSPIRED ME TO
WRITE THE BOOK.
OUR JOURNEY IS CONSTANTLY BEING
ATTACKED, WE'RE VULNERABLE AND I
WILL TELL YOU THIS WILL DESTROY
OUR INDUSTRY JUST AS BAD AS THEY
ATTEMPTED TO DO WITH COVID.
>> THERE HAS TO BE A LIMP TO
WHAT PEOPLE PUT UP WITH, A RED
LINE, IN THE FACE OF TYRANNY IN
THIS CASE.
DO YOU THINK RESTAURANT OWNERS
WOULD OBEY?
WHY DOES HOCHUL ABLE TO TELL YOU
WHAT TO DO.
>> I DID NOT OBEY KATHY HOCHUL,
OUR BILLS WILL GO SIX TIMES
HIGHER AND ON TOP OF THAT
PRODUCTIVITY DROPS, THIS WILL
NOT JUST HURT HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY, CASINOS, SHOPPING
MAUL, AIRPORTS, RESIDENTIAL
TOWERS, OFFICE BUILDINGS DEPEND
ON US FOR CONTENT AND IF WE
DON'T DEVELOP THE CONTENT FOR
BIG DEVELOPERS, THIS WHOLE THING
WILL COLLAPSE.
AGAIN, THEY ARE NOT FOLLOWING
THE SCIENCE AND THIS IS NOT
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE.
WE DON'T ALLOW COOKS TO STAND IN
SMOKE, WE HAVE A STRONG
FILTRATION SYSTEM AND THIS IS
WHAT IS NEEDED IF THEY WANT TO
GO DOWN THIS ROUTE.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE WHO SENT CRACK
PIPES TO ADDICTS AND THEY